and it'll be chris bubich for the royals
making his second start against seattle
this year and his first one was about as
high stress as you can be yes but you
know tonight it's going to be so
important for him and his bullpen
buddies sitting out there to get strike
one and get ahead of hitters
oh great change up two down
that way
thought we're going to lose him went to
a 3-0 count he came back and got him
blue kc pitch tracks early in the second
hitter down and located perfectly at 82.
his big curve his change that'll be a
nice quick out there if it comes down
and it's going to be nikki lopez he ran
a long way to get it and he helps bubba
to a scoreless top of the first and for
you 27 starts on the year seven and
eight record a 4-2-3 era and 151 innings
157 strikeouts over 58 blocks
it's amazing so they had to be patient
with him
seeger turns all the way around he
throws high
and whit gets under the tag that's got
to be a base hit all the way for sure he
spun looked like he took more time and
then when that's when he spun he
couldn't get his arm slot right
our everyday players wow that was way in
on him and he doesn't need to drop down
a bunt
to get wit to second base
and that one gets away from murphy that
looked like a cross up and so whit ends
up at third base with one out well that
change up he splits his fingers on on
that and
obviously
[Applause]
murphy wasn't looking for it
struck him out big one it's the first
inning but you want to put a little
start next to that strikeout and we're
seeing a good fastball from him four
seamer 95 miles an hour that was a
strike was on the corner topped out at
96 so far so that's a good sign
and that one is going to get through
murphy
three
wild pitches give the royals a
one-nothing lead
royals would take any gifts
they want to give them and you know
kikuchi's all over the place and murphy
not having much success with him either
in this ending alone
arlo santana thumbs one out into right
field that'll get ben and tendy to third
talking about monday and how they're
going to approach him
it's been a long inning for kikuchi and
murphy
but monteci grounds it up the middle and
he'll drive in the royals second run and
intended
comes around to score two out rallies in
the first inning
is devastating to a pitcher
he's like wow man they're not letting me
up
i'm hoping for a ground ball at somebody
look at kakuchi's reaction his head went
down immediately
let's hit the left field dylan moore
coming on he's there that'll do a couple
runs on the board one be a wild pitch
another by an rbi by monday two
another good change up he got hanager
with that pitch in the second inning and
now he gets terence
in the second well we'll see if you say
kikuchi had enough time to towel off and
catch his breath
and he grounds that one to deep third
seeger is going to throw it on a long
bounce
and dozier is going to get around it the
ball was hit hard so dozier wasn't even
out of the box yet when he grabbed it he
might have could have stopped and at
least got his feet and then used the
turf
but france comes off the base couldn't
do it
another infield hit
alberto hits one in a very shallow
center field and that's gonna be down
[Applause]
got a break right there he went fish
second strikeout for kikuchi
needed that
coming home they should get him
and they do well done
after the stolen base the infield comes
in little one hopper right to toro
throws a strike throw by abraham toro
gunned down dozier
4-2 on the put out
breaking ball struck him out for the
second time
strands two a lot of drama but it's
still two nothing kansas city
two and two to santana
in the shift toro
that's a good play
two outs
goes into the slide and from his knee
just gets rid of it one hop throws him
out by a half a step so it's a nice
defense even bobbled that a little bit
they did lost the handle good regrip
much appreciated the base hit up the
middle in the first inning was modesty's
first at-bat let's see how he does in
his second at bat
in the air
deep left field moore is back and it's
going to be off the wall
and mondassey will stop at second base
with a two-out double
taylor one for four last night after
missing four games and he has flight out
to left tonight
line center field kelnick is back still
back and it's over his head
back to back
two out doubles and the royals lead
three nothing
he absolutely crushed this
that's a fastball he stayed inside of it
with his hands and barreled it that ball
shot johann ramirez throwing his right
this will be his 20th appearance
opponents hitting just 173 against him
ramirez
got him to chase third time perez has
gone down swinging tonight on one pitch
here
stay in the yard and henniger is going
to put it away mariners survive a
situation and look forward and now
taylor michael has an rbi double and a
fly ball to left
taylor
that's deep into left center field and
gone
boy he didn't miss that that pitch
was swung on gone that quick
just short to the ball looking for the
fastball he got it and you can't hit it
on a barrel much better than that chris
has gone six he's thrown 90 pitches
tapia
and it's warmed up and ready to go so i
would assume as long as bubitch is
getting out in this inning he will stay
in
high fly ball deep left center field
long chase by taylor
and it hits off the
fence out there ben and tendy will get
it back in a leadoff double for ty
francis 28th double and the mariners get
their second hit and a good start to the
seventh inning and that will be it for
chris bubich who does something that the
royals haven't seen much certainly of
late a starter pitching into the seventh
inning but his night is now done
one hopper merryfield
let's get the meredith on the board here
rbi ground out by toro
the royals lead 4-1 in the eighth inning
they have scored all four their runs
with two outs so there has been some
clutch hitting
and given another chance
nikki lopez comes through he will drive
in one
give the fans something to talk about on
their way home
and a line drive into center field
rbi number
113 to lead the major leagues and the
royals lead 6-1 in the 8th inning and
they still have the bases loaded with
nobody out
and attendee hits it to center field
kelnick gets behind it wit tags
here he comes
here's the throw on the fly
safe
and everybody else moves up and the
royals are about to take the season
series from the mariners tonight
santana is going to get an rbi
nikki lopez comes down from third and
it's a four run
bottom of the eighth inning
so make it the royals outscoring the
mariners 19-9 he runs 15 hits for the
royals one run three hits seattle
jam
nikki lopez is there
and the royals
even the series at one game apiece
they were ahead all night
after getting two
in the bottom of the first inning
and after
getting very few innings from their
starting pitchers in the first four on
this home stand
it was chris bubich leading the way with
six in a third
giving up one run two hits